hey guys I'm Phil Molina and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 9 battle of the freakin bastards
and holy crap I told you it was going to
be insane
did I not this was one of the biggest
productions Game of Thrones has ever
done like ever probably is the biggest
actually so I'm gonna break this down
for you and point out all kinds of stuff
that made this one of the best most
emotionally destructive Game of Thrones
episodes I've ever had also heads up
we're gonna have a quick word from our
sponsor and then later in the video but
it's not gonna be too long and it's not
who you think it is but we'll get to
that for now let's get started with the
opening images so these shots of these
fireballs being loaded into catapults
and going through a pretty elaborate
process before they can fly into marine
they're visually impressive sure but
they actually don't fulfill their
meaning until you realize that we
weren't the only ones watching that
elaborate process we actually were
witnessing Danny's perspective on this
attack and these fireballs and take note
of her expression has she ever been calm
her another way to put it is she's
unimpressed when you're the mother of
dragons and they can do this it becomes
funny how hard these little guys have to
work to produce a fraction of the effect
it's like watching somebody make copy by
growing the beans and grinding them and
putting them in a coffee maker
when you're like wouldn't it be a lot
easier to just take meth I know I should
have said something like Oh use a Keurig
but I just wanted to be clear that's how
much more intense it is to have dragons
three dragons its coffee beans Timur now
quick history lesson even the Romans
actually had something cooler than these
fireballs they invented something called
Greek fire or sometimes called liquid
fire and technically we still don't even
know how they made it like what it was
comprised of it was terrifying to use in
naval battles because it could not be
put out by water you had to use sand to
suffocate the flames so they filled up
pots with this stuff and launched it at
invading armadas if this all sounds kind
of familiar that's because Greek fire is
the basis for wild fire and the Battle
of the Blackwater that was actually
based on the second Arab siege of
Constantinople funny also just like
Tyrion did in that battle they also used
a great chain as a foreign defense and
speaking of wildfire we get this moment
with Tyrion reminding Daenerys and us
that the Mad King
he had caches
five hidden under the bed keep the guild
holds the Sept of Baelor all the major
thoroughfares now if you've been
watching our breakdowns you know that
this sounds like the theory time we've
gone into more than once about what
might happen at the end of this season
with Cersei and that same fire go back
and check out one of those videos if you
want to know more but the only thing
I'll add here aside from the damage sure
sounds like that's gonna happen is that
if you listen very very closely and note
the moment the camera cuts away from
Tyrion
it sounds like part of his line was
80-yard which means recorded after they
shot this scene and an added in later
when he told my brother and Jamie told
me he had caches of wildfire hidden
under the bed keep so maybe the original
script didn't mentioned that the
wildfire was hidden underneath the red
keep itself which is the place all of
the Royals live and they had to go back
and put that line in to make sure that
Tyrion could set that up for some reason
and hmm or maybe not we will find out
soon enough also this little speech that
Tyrion is giving here it introduces us
to the themes of this episode about how
conquerors and masters alike they use
different methods to inspire a loyalty
or fealty and you think correctly the
subjects will turn against that loyalty
get burned every one of the citizens the
loyal ones and the traitors well talk
about how that applies to the Basterds
later but I will quickly point out a lot
of these guys down there are also just
slaves that aren't really loyal they're
just doing what they got to do this
whole scene by the way it introduces the
possibility that we've never really
talked about on our channel but is worth
discussing Daenerys has the instincts of
a Targaryen she wants to savagely
destroy multiple cities and kill
everyone there she definitely sounds
like a conqueror and also a little bit
crazy and let's remember crazy is
definitely in her blood so sure Tyrion
being there might make all the
difference but what if it doesn't
could Daenerys Targaryen morph into
becoming a great villain on this show
like I know it sounds crazy but let's
remember that she's about to bring a
huge horde of rapists and pillagers to
Westeros and yet she doesn't seem too
worried about it it's just something to
keep a lookout for and speaking of
keeping a lookout did you notice how the
show reused that trick from episode 3
where it looks like Danny is making eye
contact with a person that is talking
down to her but
once more she's actually looking past
them toward the source of her power her
eyes keep telling the true story of
what's about to happen now going outside
the pyramid we see that the entrance to
the city the sons of the harpy are
coordinating an attack at this same
moment which means that Terry was right
and the slave masters were aligned they
were in fact behind the sons of
heartbeat but also this might shut down
a storyline from the books in the books
there's a big deal about who the leader
of the sons of the harpy is it's implied
to be someone we already know and it's a
really big betrayal but it feels like
the show has decided to maybe eliminate
this plotline entirely and just make the
slave masters the leaders of the sons I
sure hope it's not the case though
because I love these like double-cross
II twists moments like it could be
anyone but it's probably no one no not
no one unless no it's it's definitely
not by the way there are a lot of
parallels between the two battles of
this episode and I'll point out a few
later but a pretty obvious one is that
Dany and John are both pretty lucky to
have these surprise Cavalry's at their
backs now I know we want to move on to
talking about the other epic battle but
because that battle is so big and so
much of the episode I'm gonna have a big
love letter for that later I think we
should just really quick wrap up our
points about marine and then we can move
on let's note that Daenerys still has
her babies churned really well with the
word Rick Harrison what's more wiping
out some enemies this being the third
time
and according to the books dragons are
very monogamous creatures so the fact
that she has a sort of psychic link with
all three of hers means that Danny
definitely is more than just tight with
their dragons you can tell it's a very
focused link actually because the
dragons don't go on some rampage here
they specifically focus all their flames
on only one ship it's smart because if
you look closely you can see all these
men on the other ships abandoning them
making it so that Danny can very easily
adopt this entire Navy as her own with
only one ship having received any damage
other side no it's really fun to switch
out the sound whenever you see the
Dragons breathing fire to the sound of
dragons puking their guts out
okay then grey worm touches on our
loyalty theme again when he asked the
troops why fight for men who would never
fight for you this is another parallel
to the battle to come and the way that
grey worm decides which of these masters
to execute is actually a little bit of a
reference to Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade that movie takes a biblical
theme of repentance being necessary for
salvation so thank you for giving this
for all your sins so you can get in
heaven
and it turns it into this phrase and
just like in that movie when the
penitent man kneels down for forgiveness
he's saved also in that scene this was
really easy to miss Tyrion looks away
for the entirety of the execution and at
first I thought it was because he was
being squeamish but then I remembered
that Tyrion has seen plenty of people
died and more than one at his own hands
so then I realized this is actually a
bit of a Power Move this means he's
taken away the opportunity for them to
even negotiate with him any further this
means it's now on them to determine
which of them should die and he knows if
they have to argue amongst themselves
the dishonorable ones will be known
pretty quickly he should die yes him
he's not one of us he's an outsider
lowborn he does not speak for us now
let's just knock out this scene with
Theon and Yara arriving to marine and
we'll be done with this story hunting
for the episode we learned a lot about
how surprisingly skilled Yara is with
these sort of negotiations and it's
amazing to see just how equal Danny
comes to see Yara who's the Iron Islands
ever had a queen before no more than
Westeros Dany forces people to bow to
her so it's very significant that here
the scene ends with a handshake and the
two of them standing on level ground
that's a first for Dany and it's fitting
that it comes with her first
conversation with another powerful
leading woman this union by the way is
also reminiscent of the one John had in
preparation for his battle with the same
kind of handshake but it also is in
contrast to the allegiance that's gonna
be forced upon him at the end of the
episode that definitely is not coming on
equal ground that'll be important but
we'll explain why when we get to it
lastly I'm gonna point out that we've
already said how Dany is becoming a lot
like Aegon Targaryen aka Ghandi
Conqueror who was famous for riding his
dragon into battle but what we haven't
really talked about is how he did so in
a group of three dragons except he
didn't ride alone his sister wives rode
the other dragons alongside him so could
this be where this relationship is
headed and if yare does become some sort
of sister wife to Dany and if she does
get her own dragon does that mean she
can be trusted it is worth noting that
when Danny bans the Ironborn from any
more wheezing and raping Yara barely
puts up a fight that's our way of life
no
I'm but just a few episodes ago the
unused only three words to describe Yara
she is a Riva
if ravine which means plundering like a
Viking or a Dothraki if ravine is really
that high on her list then can we really
believe that she'd let it go that easily
or is she just telling to any what she
wants to hear alright and as we
transition over to Westeros I'm just
gonna point out that earlier this season
Game of Thrones had Jon Snow be
resurrected the same day Orthodox
Christians were celebrating the
resurrection of Jesus Christ those
Easter and when this episode aired it
was all about bastard sons and a roomful
of people bad-mouthing their fathers our
fathers were evil men all of us here and
it was on Father's Day so if we extend
that thinking I wonder if anything bad
is gonna happen this upcoming Sunday
holiday which is Oh kids day oh sorry
buddy okay okay moving on to the battle
in the north we start with this parley
between the bastards and it's
interesting to hear this skewed
worldview that Ramsey has like he
doesn't know he's the villain he keeps
calling John a hostage even though it's
so is Ramsey he refers to Sansa as his
loving wife and lady Bolton's and he
even seems to call lady Mormont a
treasonous dodds when really hers is one
of the only houses that refuses to break
their oath the House Stark it's like the
opposite of treason I love this tear
down by the way that she gives him which
is made even better when you find out
that this little actress Bella Ramsey
she'd never acted before this part she's
just that scary of a child but back to
the point about being bastards obviously
it's significant as it's the title of
the episode but it's also part of this
grander theme of loyalty aside from in
Dorne being a bastard in Westeros is
kind of like the ultimate test of
loyalty you're expected to do everything
this family tells you and if it comes to
it you're supposed to fight and possibly
die for them I may be a bust it but he
is my father I'm broke is my brother
a despite being of their blood you have
no rights to their lands you're not the
heir to their titles you don't get their
last name you're not even supposed to
fly their banners a Boston boy nothing
to inherit it makes the whole concept of
a Battle of bastards pretty ironic
because if they were technically
bastards they
wouldn't even have anything to offer the
other one if they lose I know that it's
more complicated in this situation but
it still illustrates this idea pretty
well bastards don't get most of the
benefits yet they're supposed to be
totally loyal to their houses we're
gonna finish up this knot a little later
but suffice it to say that Ramsey and
John take very different paths and their
loyalty to their houses up along with my
brother where you prove this now and the
loyalty that they've earned from those
that fight for them or haven't earned
oh I will point out that before we move
on that neither of these bastard born
men follow the rule of not flying the
banners of their houses according to
Westerosi tradition they're supposed to
fly banners where the two main colors of
the house sigil have been swapped now we
can probably give Ramsey a pass because
roost did legitimize him before he died
but John technically shouldn't be flying
these though one maybe he's using
stances right to fly them and two what
was he supposed to do have everyone stop
what they're doing and so new banners so
no while I don't care that John is kind
of breaking some rules here I do think
that the banner that he's supposed to be
flying though the one with the swapped
colors is really interesting because the
stark banner is known for portraying a
grey direwolf on a white field of snow
but if you were to swap the colors
properly the white field of snow would
become a great backdrop and that
direwolf it would become white just like
ghost no word if it would need to have
red eyes though speaking of dire wolves
when Lord umber tosses shaggy dog's head
onto the battlefield there's a small
chance that this was being foreshadowed
way back in season 1
Rickon is hiding in the stark crypts
with shaggy dog and he very specifically
states
she doesn't like now first I'm gonna
remind you in the entirety of this TV
show Rickon stark has had less than like
ten lines and in all of those lines
other than when he's directly quoting
someone else the only time he ever
mentions an object it's those chains and
how shaggy dog doesn't like them and who
killed shaggy dog the umbers and what's
their house sigil chains and considering
the umbers are responsible for richens
death - breaking their stark loyalty and
taking him hostage it's a bit fitting
that immediately after Rickon says that
line he and shaggy descend back into the
darkness of the crypts together though
chains betrayed them both moving on it's
here that Sansa does her badass storm
off and it's also right after this that
ramsey mentions that he hasn't said
dogs in seven days my dogs are desperate
to meet you
I haven't fed them second a ravenous so
many of you were rightly confused about
how Sansa could know about this when she
quotes it later
in seven days you said it yourself but I
think it's okay to imagine that Sansa
just heard that detail from someone else
in her camp that scene with Sansa and
Ramsay wasn't until the next night so in
those 24 or more hours I could easily
imagine that there men who were scared
of Ramsay's numbers we're telling scary
stories about what they'd heard kind of
like help you can't help but think about
the worst possible things right before
you get on a plane
they're just sharing these horrifying
details it also could be why Ramsay
looks a little shocked when she says
that like oh huh did not know you were
aware of that okay now moving on we do
have this strategy meeting scene but I
want to get into that when we're talking
about the actual battle so I'll get back
to how strategies worked out later but
before we move forward I think it's
important to point out that with Sansa's
history she's actually right about this
no I don't think that's a reference aria
by the way I know it kind of sounds that
way I think it's just the fact that
every person whose job it's been to
protect her has failed at that Duty her
dad her fiance her first husband the
hound Littlefinger Theon her second
husband if anything it's hard to find a
single relationship for Sansa that has
ever been even a positive one maybe bran
I mean we'll see so I do get where she's
coming from welcome back to his Davos
and torment scene a little later so
let's just skip to John talking to
Melisandre two quick things to point out
here one John keeps staring into the
fire and I think that's because he knows
there's at least some truth to this Lord
of Light guy he is living proof and he's
wondering more maybe even hoping it
might be possible to get a glimpse of
the battle in the flames he wants to
know how it turns out and two Melisandre
straight up lying to dawn in this scene
like she's all meek and shy and I know
she started out this season super sad
and wimpy but we know she thinks that
because she brought John back he must be
the prince that was promised she said it
a few episodes ago he's the prince that
was promised but she also knows that she
gave Stannis way too much false
confidence by way of describing him like
a badass constantly and telling him
about her visions that cockiness was
part of his downfall so that's why I
went John
her advice all she says is news instead
of filling John in on all of her visions
basically she just doesn't want to jinx
him oh and those visions this is pretty
cool they're all coming true I've
mentioned it before but in the books
there's a moment where Melisandre is
confused she's searching her visions for
Stannis by asking the Lord of Light show
me the prince that was promised a surah
hi and she thinks something's wrong
because instead of Stannis all she keeps
seeing is snow now that's pretty obvious
that's a reference to Jon Snow but the
newer visions she's had well in the
first episode of this season she's
confused again because Jon Snow's dead
and she says in her visions
well that's now come true and last
season she said I have seen myself walk
along the battlements of Winterfell I
have seen the flayed man banners lower
to the ground that's also come true now
so on the outside she's lying but deep
down she knows it's all going according
to plan
and you know she'd got her mojo back
because she's also got her in her heat
back that is not a warm outfit she's
wearing of course we'll have to see how
long these good times last for her
because now it seems that Davos has
figured out what happened to Shireen and
there are a few things to point out with
this realization first this is a
gorgeous shot like seriously beautiful
note how the sunlight is perfectly
framed to recreate the fire that Davos
is realizing happened that's masterful
and also it's the first reference of
many to the directors inspiration for
the cinematography of the upcoming
battle scene akira kurosawa's ron will
bring that inspiration up again shortly
also this shot at the end of the scene
parallels the shot at the end of the
scene right before this one when
Melisandre was left in her tent the two
are both cast and shadow lit from behind
by a fiery orange glow and both these
people have just had basically the same
realization whatever God would kill
people for seemingly no good reason he's
a pretty crappy guard could it cope what
do something know that it wouldn't we've
got and then finally this scene
perfectly sets up what's about to happen
because we've just been reminded of what
Stannis did when he had to choose
between the life of a child from his
family and his own success in battle and
now John is gonna face the same dilemma
and call it stupid if you want but the
fact that his battle plans go out the
window when Rickon is in danger
the only further shows the loyalty that
this bastard has for his quasi family
even outweighs that of the supposedly
noble father and his highborn daughter
now before we get into this bloodbath
part of the battle let's not just skip
over the fact that Rickon has died first
off Ramsey's sadistic game and skill
with the bow and arrow they're actually
foreshadowed way back in the very first
time we ever saw Ramsay and I know you
probably thought Rick and should have
zigzag even the actor did too actually
but the poor kid had no idea what he was
doing and if you've seen Apocalypto it
turns out zigzagging doesn't always help
and throughout the rest of the episode
we're gonna keep calling out some
amazing choices of the director made to
keep increasing the tension until we
were literally feeling the stress in
these moments ourselves here's one
brilliant choice riggan runs and Ramsay
pulls back the arrows and we cut away
waiting for that release and he keeps
dragging it out and he does this once
and then again and then we've got the
big dramatic one the rule of threes and
that one misses - looking at Ramsay's
face and knowing that he's a very
skilled Archer
he's definitely missing on purpose he's
drawing it out as long as possible and
then suddenly without any build-up
retention boom and arrow just shoots
through richens chest the director sets
us up with expectations gives us a
pattern to recognize and then he
suddenly changes all of it to hit us
with as much surprised as hits Rickon
and then breaking is dead and three
theories are completed - I've told you
about before we talked about how the
name of his direwolf shaggy dog refers
to a story where it seems like a
character is gonna have some big
important story and instead he just kind
of suddenly dies without having really
accomplished much I'm also talking about
how the waist training of Aria seemed to
match up with violent attacks on people
that already cares about and Rickon was
included in that montage but here's a
new one I haven't mentioned before in
the very first episode of Game of
Thrones Robert Baratheon arrives in
Winterfell and he touches specific
members of the stark family Eddard Kalen
Rickon and Robb now with Rick and Ed
each of those Starks has died and you
could say the curse of Roberts touch is
complete now if you're wondering why
Robert would have anything to do with
the death of those Starks let's remember
what else happens in that pilot episode
this Starks find a litter of dire wolves
whose mothers just died the direwolf is
the sigil of house Stark and what killed
this dire wolf a stag the sigil of house
Baratheon it's long been predicted and
now it seems pretty true that the Brad
hands would bring about the downfall of
House Stark
so I'd note that same scene with robber
where he touches the now-deceased
characters check out what he asks Aria
the old name is she can't get away from
that question and they've been setting
it up since the beginning oh and
speaking of no one that's who our
sponsor is no one
there's no sponsor instead of that I
actually have a short announcement to
make hopefully you've been enjoying
these breakdowns they are very fun to
make and I feel like we built this
badass community here of people who
really seemed to care as much about
nerdy stuff as we do that's why we so
badly want to grow this channel into
some epic nerd sanctuary where we can
explore way more nerd properties at any
given time and to make this legit we've
taken your advice we've joined patreon
if you don't know patreon it's a site
that lets you all watching make
recurring contributions directly to us
to help us make the things that you're
watching the circle of life of you will
and any contribution can actually make a
big difference the way the math works
out if even just half of you were to
send us the equivalent of a $1 cup of
coffee each month it would totally add
up you are also welcome to donate more
for whatever you're comfortable with but
the point is as more of you donate we'd
actually start to scale this channel up
more and more and our current team could
start working full-time we'd hire more
editors we'd launch new shows and
eventually we'd start releasing videos
every single day for instance I've got
so many Game of Thrones theory and
historical connection videos that are
sitting in my head right now that I'm
desperate to make so if you've got a
second now or after the video is done
head on over to patreon comm slash new
rockstars and check out all the stuff we
have planned to do like getting our
videos translated into more languages
which is something a lot of you have
been asking for and also check out the
perks that you get when you sign up to
be one of our supporters things like
exclusive theory and QA articles that
are gonna be released only on patreon or
early access to our videos or video
chatting with us about all things nerdy
& hué thank you in advance for anything
you're able to contribute to help us
make more of these videos you guys are
great
let's move on oh and we're moving on
right into theory time
we're still talking about Rick and Stark
and while it's sad that he's gone you
can find some comfort and one thing John
says I think that's really important
skip to this time if you don't want to
know why but Rickon always loved the
crypts he felt very safe there
it's where he was hiding in that scene
earlier so it is nice that he gets to
spend eternity there however the fact
that it sounds like John is gonna be the
one to take him down in there well
that's interesting because you know who
else is laid to rest down there Lyanna
stark Ned's sister and if the theory is
true John's real mother but why is that
a big deal because John has dreamt of
this moment and the crypts multiple
times in the books he very vividly
describes this dream to his buddy Sam he
says he finds himself wandering the
crypts he knows he has to go in but he
doesn't know why the old kings of winter
are down there but it's not them he's
afraid of in other descriptions he hears
whispers that he's not a stark so if
he's not afraid of the old kings of
winner then what is he afraid o could it
be his mother Liana
well John examining her tomb lead him to
discovering the truth about his own
parentage and that he isn't a stark he's
a Targaryen or maybe even worse would he
learn not only who his parents are but
maybe something terrible about them we
all know that his mother could be Lyanna
stark and his father could be Rhaegar
Targaryen but what if he learned
something like Liana didn't want him to
survive but we know Liana's last words
were promised me Ned and I would bet
money by the way that we will see more
of the Tower of joy
next episode probably through Brant and
I expect to hear that line but what if
that promise was not a good one like
maybe it's not a promise to care for the
baby but a promise to kill the baby
because he's an heir to the Targaryen
throne and maybe Liana hated Rhaegar I
know that sounds like a lot of maybes
but it would explain not only why Jon
would be scared of this dream revelation
which would be so dark by the way and we
know George R Martin likes dark but also
it would explain why when Ned was having
nightmares way back when he dreams of
blood and broken promises why would they
be broken promises if all she wanted was
him to take care of Jon or even hide his
identity he did those things but if she
asked him to kill the baby well then
that definitely would be a broken
promise also though maybe it could be
something way less dark like him maybe
he finds just evidence of
Liyana having been married or something
and he's not such a bastard his parents
were actually married each other
Targaryen did allow for polygamous
marriage or as is always the case at
their time maybe it's nothing but I'll
be damned if we get through the next
episode and we don't at least have the
strongest teasing hint ever that Rhaegar
and Lyanna are John's parents okay back
to normal man and we're on to the battle
and yes this was the most amazing battle
the show has had yet the director that I
keep referencing his name is miguel
zapata and he also directed hardhome
last year which was the second most
amazing battle now that the show that
this guy the genius and actually i feel
like so much has already been said about
this battle i'm gonna try to stick to
mostly stuff that I haven't seen around
a lot let's dive in but first let's
clarify the Stork strategy that they
were supposed to use in case you missed
it
the Starks were supposed to hold back
and just wait the Bolton army out it's
crucial that we let them charge at us
when the Bolton army has had enough
waiting and charges they won't be able
to spread out and come around the sides
of the force because the stark men dug
trenches on the sides of the battlefield
so it'll create a lane that they have to
stay inside her once the Bolton's drive
up the center the center of the stark
force would retreat backward causing the
Bolton's to chase them but letting the
stark forces surround them on the two
other sides and making the Bolton's have
to fight the battle on three fronts at
the same time it's actually a pretty
brilliant strategy and now here's the
miserable part of it it's exactly well
Ramsay ends up doing to the Starks
Ramsay draws them out first not once but
twice and then he actually 1ups their
plan by surrounding them not just on
three sides but by adding that wall of
the Dead and having Lord umber drive up
the rear they actually surround them on
four sides honestly it's pretty genius
and the historical precedents for these
strategies is really well known but I
gotta take off I'm going to VidCon right
now so Eric is gonna tag in and help
break down the rest of the episode feel
free to tweet at me or hit me up on
Facebook for any questions you have
directly for me yes I think next week's
episode is going to be crazy especially
considering how much stuff they have to
wrap up but I gotta go my ride is here
I'll see you next time bye hey guys Eric
taking over now to talk about the real
nerdy stuff history this is uh so like
Philip said Miguel Capote Nick looked to
a bunch of famous historical battles to
inspire the war strategy that we saw in
battle the bastards so let's get started
okay so first is the Battle of Agincourt
between England and France in 1415
during the Hundred Years War so in that
battle the outnumbered English forces
plan to use the same let them
charge at us tactic that Davos and John
1d used except just like John the
English were forced to charge first but
one of the big reasons Ashton Court is
famous is it was one of the first times
the longbow is used so predominantly now
the longbow is a lot taller than other
types of bows it lets archers fire from
long ranges and just like an Asian court
a lot of the deaths we see in the battle
the bastards are from arrows and pretty
much all of these arrows are coming from
Ramsay's side Davos backs down because
he doesn't want to kill his own men just
come on men stunned um but Ramsay
doesn't care he just ordered his all of
his men now why is this important two
reasons one Ramsay's using another
strategy borrowed from battles of
history and it's a pretty dark one using
mounds of corpses to boxing the enemy
now in the American Civil War and
several other high casualty wards
several first-hand accounts described
bodies piling up so high that they were
becoming literal obstructions on the
battlefield but - this brings up that
recurring theme of loyalty that filled
was talking about earlier using arrows
like this was also tactic used by
Ramsay's father Roose Bolton during the
battle the green fork that's the one
where Tyrion got knocked out in the show
but in the book
Tyrion notices that arrows are raining
down into the melee killing men on both
sides and he shot that Roose would even
order that ruses men are not that
important and they're like pawns or
beasts for the slaughter it's one-sided
loyalty coming from Bruce also while I'm
on this point remember Ramsay was
conceived when Roose raped a woman under
the hanging body of her husband so
really it was Roose Bolton who instilled
this whole old-school feudal ideology
into the Bolton family this idea of
one-sided loyalty and then that idea is
the same thing that inspired Ramsay to
kill Roose
just like it will end up doing Ramsay in
as well but getting back to the
historical background of this battle
scene this shot of Jon getting trampled
by his own men in the mud nearly
suffocating that's actually something
that happened to the soldiers in the
Battle of Agincourt men were literally
stampeded and buried alive underneath
corpses drowning as mud seeped into
their helmets so if you felt
claustrophobic during the scene Congrats
that's exactly how those soldiers felt
but in real life we survived
they didn't were the lucky ones we don't
have to fight in wars that's great but
anyway I'll come back to this shot
there's another famous battle that
inspired the direction of the Battle of
the Battle of kanae so when we see the
Bolton soldiers encircling John's army
with these shields that was based on the
same tactic used in the battle kanay
that was fought between the Romans and
the Carthaginians in 216 BC the
Carthaginians led by Hannibal and
circled the Romans with their shields
and killed him off now the show actually
designed the shield wall using the same
structure by the soldiers who had
shields back in the Roman times it's
several layers deep with the frontline
just holding the shields in the line
behind it poking these Pike's through
also the chanting that you hear tactic
from the soldiers back in those days it
worked both as a form of intimidation
and as a way to synchronize their
movements since they couldn't really see
each other also should probably point
out that seeing shields used in battle
is actually a really rare thing for Game
of Thrones they pretty much never use
shields that's probably because they're
heavy props and they obstruct the
camera's view of the actors but here
shields are a game changer in this
battle just like they were in most
styles of history also it's cool to see
that they made a miniature version of a
shield for the actor playing 1:1 so
aside from the history that inspired the
strategy of this battle let's talk about
some of the cinematic influences so this
type of battle is called a pitch field
battle in the director McGill Capote
Nick watched as many famous movie hits
field battles that he could find so
Phillip mentioned this earlier but one
of the major film influences on this
battle scene was the movie run by
Japanese film director Akira Kurosawa
now Ronn is a movie that shows these
famous aerial shot battle scenes with
horses and Men just slamming against
each other over and over again until we
don't feel anything anymore
Kurosawa's goal was to condemn the
horror of war and to show a time without
loyalty or fealty he shot things from an
overhead perspective toward the ground
rarely showing us the sky because he
wanted to show us things from the gods
perspective as we saw men slaughter each
other
suppose Mick wanted to evoke that same
condemnation of war intentionally
showing us violent stabs and hits
without focusing on the victim he also
emphasizes the role of randomness and
luck in battle arrows are landing all
around Jon and killing people around him
but notice none of them actually hit him
it's a miracle
and in several shots threats get taken
out before John even sees them now you
could call this luck or a plot armor or
even Melisandre's protection cells but
it's clearly by design but the poach
Nick intentionally deviates from
Kurosawa in a few key ways the first is
that he shifts from these aerial shots
in
John's perspective he wants us to
empathize with John sense of panic check
out this one-minute tracking shot where
the camera never cuts as John fights
through the melee like he's trapped in
the middle of traffic the shot conveys
the horror of war but from John's eyes
in particular I feel like it's inspired
by that famous long take from children
of men where the chaos unfolds around a
character while the camera never cuts
away these kind of shots pull you into
the action like you're in the middle of
hell with the character quick missable
moment I want to point out here when
John spins around to swing at this ride
or about to slash with him check out how
his Valyrian steel sword totally
shatters this other guy's sword you can
see the chunks of it flying away his
sword doesn't break up all the swords
that it comes to contact with during
this battle but this guy on horseback is
coming up at a greater speed
either way John's sword is super
effective it's a cool detail that they
worked in there like Kurosawa Capote
Nick uses a long lens now a long lens
compresses objects in the foreground
with objects in the background Kurosawa
used it for a few reasons he liked how
it flattened an image similar to the way
Japanese art is two-dimensional and it
also saved him a lot of money because he
wouldn't have to show a lot of detail in
the background that way Capote Nick also
uses a long lens but he finds a new
effective way to use it check out this
shot in particular of John as he faces
off against the charging Bolton cavalry
the long lens makes the horses look a
lot closer than they are in real life it
feels claustrophobic like they're
closing in on them that way the director
can make the horses look like they're
running into each other are closing in
on each other rather than actually
slamming the animals into each other and
hurting them which Kurosawa
unfortunately did because it was the 50s
and the standards for animal safety on
film sets didn't really exist and I
talked about this earlier but that
claustrophobia and that empathy really
comes across in these shots of John
being trampled we physically cannot
breathe we feel that pressure too and
when John finally emerges and gasps for
air then we can finally inhale there's a
similar shot in Kill Bill Vol - if you
saw that movie where the bride has to
crawl out of a grave and we can't
breathe until she does fun fact
Tarantino is also influenced by Kurosawa
when he was making those movies now that
actually brings up a ton of other
cinematic references that this battle
sequence makes so I'm gonna try to go
through all the ones that I spotted
first off Braveheart is a clear
influence on the scene it was one of the
first movies to show a graphic pitch
field battle from the ground perspective
but close-ups of men clashing and really
cutting into each other with lots of
gore and
said not just lightly slashing swords
and moving on
similarly this battle scene covers all
the soldiers with mud and blood no one
is clean there's also similar shots of
arrows raining down on soldiers also the
sharpened bone that we see tormund used
to stab umber is similar to the antler
William Wallace uses also I feel like I
should point out that Jew or Mormont
even though he's long dead and the game
of Thrones universe was another actor in
Braveheart and a lot of these shots seem
inspired directly from movie Lord of the
Rings Return of the King like that
slow-motion shot of the horses galloping
looks a lot like the ones from the
famous Faramir charge montage that's one
weird Pippin singing also this shot of
John facing off solo against the cavalry
looks a lot like Aragorn at the Black
Gate which also has a similar aerial and
closing circle shot like the one from
this episode also when they hear the
horns of the Knights of the Vale that's
similar to the horns of rohan in the
Battle of Palin our fields
and the way that the Knights of the Vale
sweep across the Bolton's like a wave
parallels the army of the Dead in that
battle but before I move on there's just
a few more miserable details that I want
to point out like notice how when John
emerges from the sea of bodies this shot
mirrors that overhead shot of Daenerys
surrounded by people in that Mesa scene
now the season keeps showing his
parallel shots of John and Daenerys and
all that is obviously intentional and if
Daenerys becomes increasingly villainous
like Phillip was talking about earlier
it could mean a conflict that's brewing
between these two also I thought it was
interesting how torment oook this big
bite out of umbers neck that reminded me
of the bite that Brienne took out of the
Hound during their close quarters fight
really think these two are just made for
each other and check out this shot of
Sansa the camera zooms right past
Littlefinger because in this moment at
least
this isn't his victory it's Sansa's
seibert's arises away from Jon and it
looks like she's feeling guilty here
because she showed more loyalty the
little finger than to her half-brother
and John is like what the f honey you
tell me about these guys come on and
yeah that is the big question we all
have right like why didn't Sansa tell
John about Littlefinger in the Knights
of the Vale actually think the next
episode is gonna address this bully but
for now I have a few theories why Sansa
didn't tell him one in the days leading
up to the battle since I could see how
emotional and impulsive Jon was being
and she didn't want to hand over her ace
in the hole to get mostly wiped out in
the opening melee when Jon Leroy Jenkins
to cross the battlefield she wanted to
hold off until they would be more
effective later in a battle but - I
think this could have been a tactic
coming from little fingers remember he
made that deal with Cersei last season
before the First Battle of Winterfell
between the Bolton's and Stannis at
Stannis and Roose battle at the enemies
of the throne slaughter each other and
when they're done seize Winterfell from
whichever thief survives and if you
succeed name me warden of the north
hanging back to let both sides wipe each
other out while he swoops in at the end
to tip the scale that was always
Littlefinger's plan and now he has by
far the largest army in the north maybe
all of Westeros and he's poised to
become warden of the north if he follows
through on his deal with Cersei
no no you're a man of your word
and I see some stocks head down a spike
but whatever the reason she didn't tell
him in this shot you can see what Philip
was talking about earlier that John is
not on equal ground with the steel and
he's being forced into an allegiance
that he didn't really agree - that's not
true loyalty and I think Littlefinger
could end up being a big problem for
John in the near future
so one one class to the gates of
Winterfell and there's a lot of layers
to this callback good I really like on
one level it's a callback to win one one
plowed through the gates of Castle black
back in episode 2 of this season doors
clearly aren't a problem for this guy
but remember one one was the last giant
and one of the other last Giants was the
one that we saw who smashed through the
other side of Castle black it was
interesting how in that season foreseen
we really want to see that giant get
taken down but this time we feel the
opposite we're on the wildling side and
of course one one giving his life at a
door is a mirror image of Hodor is death
one giant held the door this other giant
brought it down and we cried at both
also this one might be a stretch but
this reminds me of the scene in season 4
with Sansa and Robin in the Eyrie where
Robin stomped and kicked over Sansa snow
model of Winterfell just like a giant
here we see another giant breaking into
Winterfell the same way so I don't know
about you but here's a question I had
about Ramsay in this moment now if he
could shoot one one in the eye here why
doesn't he just shoot Jon like he
clearly didn't aim for dawn and Miss and
hate one one that was an intentional
move so when you think about it either
way Ramsay knows he's a dead man
but if he shoots Jon when he's not
looking one one or torment or one of the
other wild lands is just going to
pulverize them without thinking twice
but leaving Jon alive keeps the game
going he's able to bathe him back in a
single combat which is what Jon
initially proposed he suggested one on
one comeback in G so pissing off Jon but
not killing him still gives Ramsay a
fighting chance also I like this detail
here notice how John uses the Mormont
shield to block Ramsay's arrows so even
though he was only able to get 62
soldiers from house Mormont their shield
is saving his life several times over so
it's just pointing out how Jon needed
every bit of help he could get to take
back his home so when Jon finally takes
down Ramsay he lets his emotion take
over again the director actually told
Kit Harington to play this like he was
beating an animal with no regard for
Ramsay at all and kit responded that he
would make it look like he was needing
bread the idea was that this should be
an empty victory for Jon a nosedive into
darkness so that it would set up
handing this over to Sansa to finished a
job again Sansa's pragmatism is
outweighing John's impulsiveness and
emotion but if you look closely at this
overhead shot someone else's stand in
this courtyard that none of the angles
show little finger it's like the scene
went out of his way not to give him his
own shot
so as usual Littlefinger stays the man
behind the scenes looming over
everything waiting for other people to
do the heavy lifting so that he can pick
up the pieces when the dust settles so
this shot of a Bolton banner dropping
and being replaced with a stark banner
is such a satisfying victory moment kind
of like seeing the American flag being
raised at Iwo Jima if you're American
you're from any other country just to
replace that with your country's flag
it'll be great to see the Bolton flayed
man on Winterfell get replaced with the
stark dire wolf in the opening credits
next episode just like the gods intended
it to be so moving on to the final scene
when Sansa confronts Ramsay and even
though this is clearly the end for him
he still acts like he's in control time
together he invoked the famous
historical Hannibal during the battle
but now he invokes another famous
Hannibal from movies creepily greeting
us from behind bars and so we're keeping
the Ramsay horror tropes going with
sounds of the Lambs but Ramsay reminds
me of another caged movie villain in the
way he tells Sansa I bought you it's
like he's telling her that he turned her
from the innocent caged bird into an
evil ruthless person just like he is or
in other words there's actually another
Dark Knight connection in the scene that
I'll get to in a second so a lot of
people were thinking that Ramsay's
saying I botch it might mean he
impregnated her I guess it's possible I
mean we did see Sansa solely new clothes
early this season and she had a
different appetite back in Castle black
and I guess those heavy cloaks are hide
her body shape but I'm kind of leaning
against it just because it seems like
the show is ending this storyline with
Ramsay's death and considering it must
have taken at least a few months for
John and sanstead a crisscross the North
to build up their troops I feel like she
would have started showing by now okay
so there's a couple things that I want
to point out in the background here
first off this black dog that emerges
from the shadows feel like it could be a
reference to the Grimm which is a black
dog that's an omen for death just like
Ramsay's death is imminent but check out
how the editing matches up with Santa's
words when Ramsay
looking out the snowy window no name
will disappear
well memory of G will disappear Ramsay
has been obsessed with names this
episode and pretty much the entire time
that we've known him becoming a Bolton
was a huge deal for his character now
tell me what is your name
Ramsay snow from this day until your
last day you are Ramsay Bolton son of
Roose Bolton warden of the north
you honor me and all episode he was
revenant in other people's faces busted
busted busted but now Sansa is taking
that name back from him he's back to who
he was before Ramsay snow and what is he
looking at through the window snow and
that brings the store closing images fur
and Z being stripped of his place in
history transforms him from a lord who
could command loyalty and fealty to a
bastard with no real claim and no one
boiled to him unlike the bastard who won
this battle Ramsay treated his men like
beasts sending them to be slaughtered by
his own arrows and literally starving
these dogs for seven days literally
everyone who has served Ramsay has been
a victim of his cruelty
Theon Sansa Roose Bolton his own
soldiers every woman he's ever slept
with and they're all hungry to turn on
him now so when he says my eyes will
never hugged me
they're loyal beasts it brings up
another line from the Joker and then
we'll see how loyal everyone in this
episode is repaying cruelty by breaking
loyalty these dogs with Ramsay a former
slave like grey worm killing the Masters
and this wife turning on her husband
earlier this season when Ramsay stuck
his hounds on fat Walda and the baby the
camera luckily didn't show us that
violence but this time Sansa forces us
to watch she starts to turn away but
then she decides I need to see this and
so does the audience the dog repays
Ramsay's lack of loyalty with the bite
to the Jon neck and as you hear in
serene you can almost make out the
squeal of a pig that was actually an
intentional move by the director in the
sound designer that's because the
director learned that when human
windpipe is severed it makes the same
kind of wheeze sound pretty graphic
don't get any ideas kylo and I love this
- check this out when Sansa walks away
she does it in the same exact camera
frame that we saw Jon when his watch was
ended back in episode 3 and how she left
the faceless men last episode all these
closing images are exactly the same that
makes three Starks who are now rushing
off the things that were holding them
back ready to reclaim the home that was
always there ok so a few lingering
questions one do you think Sansa was
being manipulative the season remember
back in episode 4 Sansa convinced Jon to
march on Winterfell specifically to save
Rick on a monster has taken our home and
our brother but in this episode she
pretty much assumes Rickon is going to
die anyway what should we do how do we
get Rick on back never get him back so
I'm wondering if this whole battle was
just so Sansa could get her revenge on
Ramsay not to say that she's wrong for
one in that or Ramsay doesn't deserve
revenge he totally does but to sacrifice
lives of thousands of men just for your
own selfish desire for revenge seems
like it's a big deal for Sansa notice
the smile on her face when she's walking
away in the closing shot she looks
pretty satisfied with herself and if
this is really the case uh means the
answer really has taken a dark turn
and that Ramsay really is a part of her
now also now that Ramsay Bolton is gone
who was the main villain of Westeros now
now obviously the night king is the
supernatural big bad for the end game of
Game of Thrones but I'm wondering which
human will step up as the most ruthless
Philip will talk about Daenerys before
Littlefinger is now the guy
with the largest army in Westeros maybe
and he has his thumb over three of the
Seven Kingdoms so this guy is really
looking like the evil genius and I'm
curious to see what his next move is and
of course if our theories about Cersei
end up being true she may go full circle
from the Evil Queen that we hated in the
first season or the empathetic mother
that we got to know and so the later
seasons back to being the Evil Queen
again but we'll have to see what happens
next episode also this may just be me
but I'm curious are we gonna see a naval
battle on the show Daenerys is now
headed west with her small fleet
composed to the ships that she got from
the Masters and the ones brought by Yara
and Theon but we know that you're on is
building his thousand ships and heading
east to meet her so this would set up an
interesting conflict we know the
Dothraki don't sail well and the
Ironborn boarding parties seem like
they'd be more useful in a battle at sea
as opposed to dragons who just burn
everything in sight and if Philips idea
of Daenerys and Yara riding the two
dragons ends up happening who do you
think will be riding that third dragon
let me know what you think and again if
you like what we do here at new
rockstars and you want to contribute
make sure to check out our patreon page
seriously we're a tiny operation here
it's just Phillip and me and Ted and
Kyle oh and if you help us out I promise
you'll really start to see a difference
in how fast and frequent we can get
these videos out also check out our past
breakdown to the other Game of Thrones
episodes this season and look out for a
breakdown on the season finale next week
and make sure to subscribe to new
rockstars and like this video share it
around it's another way you can help
grow this channel you can follow us on
twitter at new rock stars or hit a
fillip on twitter at fimo or me at EA
vos can also get in touch with Phillip
on Facebook at facebook.com slash mo
nose okay that's it thanks for watching
everyone see you next week bye